at the Berlin Wall memorial unsung Succi
observed firsthand our Germany is coming
to terms with its own dictatorial past
the Burmese opposition leader viewed the
recreation of Berlin's infamous wall
during her visit to the German capital
the nobel peace prize winner hopes
germany will continue to support
political change in my and mark
elections are scheduled for next year
and sookie isn't being coy about her
political ambitions if I could I would
be very happy to become president not
because i think it's a it's an easy post
but because i owe it to our people that
is to say those in the forces of
democracy who have worked very hard to
achieve the kind of society where we can
choose their those whom we wish to need
the government suci also visited the
Brandenburg Gate famous symbol of German
division and reunification it looks very
familiar because I have seen so many
photographs of it in the park Suchi
cautioned myanmar has not yet made the
transition to full democracy and that
the reform process must continue much
like germany she said her country would
need time to repair the damage done
during 50 years of military rule